So let's first look at the methods
that try to reduce hit time.
Some of the methods are pretty obvious,
like reduce the cache size.
That's going to improve the hit time,
but this is bad for the miss rate.
So the overall aim at might not actually
be improved, because we are going to
Improve the hit time, but we're going to
increase the miss rate and thus,
pay more of those miss
penalties that are quite large.
So we can do this, but we have to do it
carefully to balance the miss rate and
the hit time.
The next simple method is to
use the cache associativity.
This is going to make the cache faster,
because we need to search in only one or
few places for a block on a hit,
but this is also bad for
miss rate for similar reasons.
When we reduce associativity,
we are creating more messes.
Because blocks is going to start having
conflicts and start kicking each other
out, even though they might coexist
peacefully in a more associative cache.
So the less simple methods for
a use in hit time involve overlapping
the cache hit with another hit.
Overlapping the cache
hit with the TLB axis.
Optimizing the lookups,
so that common cases get faster without
sacrificing the uncommon case too much
and maintaining the replacement
state in the cache more quickly.
So on hits, we need to update some
state that we will need later for
replacements and
we can make this more efficient.
So we will look at four methods
that are trying to achieve these
four things here.